El Nino is a global weather pattern that
follows its sister event La Nina on
average every two to seven years it
starts when trade winds that blow east
to west just north and south of the
Equator change direction and begin to
weaken the Pacific Ocean heats up along
the Equator and blows warm air towards
Central America that brings severe
weather to the entire world increased
rainfall and floods in some areas
drought in others
by declaring the start of an El Nino
year the United Nations hopes
governments will prepare information we
are providing as if you like a global
scale perspective so detailed
implication of El Nino remain at the
core or in the hand of the member
country which need to Define refine the
information so we're providing the
global teacher and every region will
have the detailed picture of the
implication
and that's where it gets complicated
because the local effects can be
different and severe while droughts
strike Central and Southern Africa India
Indonesia Australia and Northern Brazil
rain pours over the southern U.S parts
of South America the Horn of Africa and
Central Asia storms in the Atlantic
weaken while those in the Pacific
strengthen
this weather fluctuation often leads to
a rise in commodity prices on wheat from
Australia palm oil coffee and even
nickel from Indonesia Copper from Peru
and fuel more in demand as hydropower
dries up analysts say governments will
need to come up with a plan to tackle
each of these challenges in our research
we do show that the effects of El Nino
work themselves out within four to six
quarters so the the economic impacts of
El Nino will only last for about a year
or year and a half in some countries up
to two years
but a study from Dartmouth University in
the U.S showed that after the last three
El ninos the world's economy lost
trillions of dollars
the other reason we're getting larger
costs I think than previous estimates is
because we are allowing for the
possibility that El Nino influences more
than just tropical countries and when
you do that you actually find that there
are really no places in the world that
that actually benefit from El Nino
events and so you just get this much
larger fingerprint in terms of global
macroeconomic effects
all of this on a planet that is hotter
than ever before in modern history Colin
Baker Al Jazeera